تعرض قناه الجزيره مساء اليوم الجمعه
تحقيقا خاصا من برنامج ما خفي اعظم
بالتزامن مع الذكرى السنويه الاولى
لاغتيال الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله على يدي
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واجرى مقدم
البرنامج الزميل تامر المسحال لقاءات
حصريه لا سيما مع الخبير الامريكي الذي
تولى عمليه تحليل المقاطع المصوره
والصوتيه لجريمه الاغتيال والذي حسم الجدل
في مصدر الرصاصه التي قتلت الزميله شيرين
اثناء تغطيتها الميدانيه في جنين التحقيق
الذي يحمل عنوان قتل الادله يكشف بالوثائق
والشهادات السياسه الاسرائيليه الممنهجه
في التهرب من العقاب في قضايا قتل
الصحفيين في فلسطين كما يتضمن التحقيق
مقابلات مع محققين دوليين حققوا في قضايا
اغتيال صحفيين على يد جيش الاحتلال ما خفي
اعظم اكل الادله ياتيكم مساء اليوم الجمعه
عند العاشره وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه على شاشه الجزيره ومنصاتها
المختلفه
الان